For this first equation, x plus 5 equals x plus 7, the right side of the
equation is always going to be 2 greater than the left side, since 7 is 2
greater than 5. Since no value of x can make these two sides equal to each
other, this is not an equation. There is some number that we can substitute for
x though, in the second equation, that gives us 27 when we multiply it by 3. So,
what times 3 equals 27? 9. So, this is an equation. However, other numbers that
we can put into x like zero would not make this true, so this has to be a
conditional equation. Our third equation is the same type as the second one.
Since some values of x make this true. And our last equation is an identity. If
we simplify the expression that we have on the left-hand side, we can combine
like terms, since we know that x and 2x are like terms. And we can make the
left-hand side equal to 3x plus 3, which is exactly the same as the right-hand
side. No matter what we plug in for x, these two will be equal. So this is an
identity.